whoa whoa sorry guys
i thought this was the bathroom hello
and welcome to playstation grenade
a year ago i showed you an up-and-coming
looter shooter from the creators of
gears of war and some of the devs
behind fortnite this is outriders
and you know me i love to promote games
that let players get their hands on some
gameplay without shelling over any cash
right now you can play the first section
of outriders totally free
to see if it's your kind of game i've
teamed up with square enix to break down
why you should try it for yourself
and to help you pick a class too as this
is a sponsored post there is a custom
link in the description below
should you want more info about the
platform you play on and by the way it's
a cross-play title so playstation xbox
pc
and even stadia can all play together
anyway enough intro
let's look at outriders
outriders to me is a blend of a bunch of
great games namely destiny
borderlands and the division so right
away if you enjoy
any of those titles this one deserves
your attention
the story follows humanity as it's
forced to leave earth
which has become a barren waste ground
kinda like the city i live in
you'll be playing through those events
and experiencing what gave us our
abilities
and powers i really want to talk about
those powers and who you should choose
on your first playthrough
because in my opinion that is the
element of outriders which is the most
unique aspect
outriders is a looter shooter which as
you know means we shoot many enemies who
then drop loot which we use to upgrade
our character
rinse and repeat the weapons upgrade the
clothing stats upgrade
basically numbers keep going up that is
the addictive element to this type of
outing
in addition to tons of guns our
outriders are altered beings who possess
very unique abilities which are classed
in four ways
okay i can't wait any longer take a look
at this
these are the abilities of my personal
favorite class in outriders
known as the trickster each character we
pick
can harness three skills at once i'm
gonna stick to the first three you'll
encounter in the demo
for each class the first trickster
ability is temporal blade
which paralyzes and slices an enemy
right in front of your eyes
and more likely than not they'll explode
in a bony burst
oh it's satisfying the second ability is
the most awe-inspiring thing of beauty
the slow trap it's like a destiny titan
bubble
yet it's not a shield bullets can
permeate this
but once those bullets are inside they
slow down
and so do the enemies too slow motion
this allows us the trickster to get
heavy damage on foes
and teaming it with the first ability we
get this and if all that wasn't enough
the third ability
lets the trickster utilize something
called hunt the prey
it's basically a teleporter which lets
us land right behind the enemy
they do react pretty quickly but if you
have a shotgun this
can be ultra satisfying here's all three
powers in a single play
i've got a feeling i like this a little
too much and remember that's only the
first three abilities each class
has five more so the trickster
manipulates time and space to get up
close and personal with enemies but if
that's not your bag then try the
technomancer
a long range class with gadgets like
those found in borderlands
have a look-see the technomancer's first
ability is a grenade effectively
a mine which can be thrown pretty far
distances
it then waits to be triggered and pops
up to cause maximum damage
this is to keep enemies away from the
technomancer
range is key to this class the second
ability is the cryo turret
it's like a thrown down extra companion
which gains aggro
it deals freeze damage and can be used
to flank enemies or trap them
if you're playing solo this is a great
thing to have with you
but by far the best thing of the first
three abilities is the pain
launcher that's legit its name a missile
launcher that decimates everything it
hits
even working across chasms and behind
cover
really fun to use
let's go back to close up and in your
face action with the devastator
the devastator utilizes the ground
beneath our feet
to get the edge in battle these guys are
like the tank class of the group
and they're happy to take damage as long
as they're dealing damage
what makes this class feel great is the
third ability unlocked
the gravity leap we take to the skies
then select a target
to crush them with rocks and rubble
there's a certain satisfaction to using
your butt
as a weapon the devastator also has a
seismic interrupt which is a punch to
the ground
causing her like a micro earthquake of
damage and interrupts enemies
and finally look at this additional
armor is added which absorbs
65 percent of all attacks it's a thing
of beauty
and keep in mind there's another five
abilities to unlock after this point
like a spike that impales falls there's
some impressive mechanical depth here
and finally we have the pyromancer the
medium range jack of all trades
master of none class but this guy has
little fire
at their fingertips firstly you'll
unlock heatwave a wall of fire flies
towards and ignites enemies
putting them in a fit of panic we then
have the feed the flames ability which
is like a whip of fire
kinda like scorpions get over here in
moral combat
but not bringing them too close because
the pyromancer is a medium-range unit
it deals damage and inflicts ash 2. and
now we're talking
ability 3 is the thermal bomb take a
look at this
the ability burns an enemy and if their
health is low enough to eliminate them
they'll literally explode it's another
ability which does not get old it's a
thing of beauty
especially when there are other enemies
to take damage from that explosion
so which of these classes is for you i'm
a trickster main right now
get in hit and run get away and remember
those are only 12 unlockable
skills there's another 20 to find in
your own time there is far more to each
class but i wanted to show you
the wow factor things over the subtle
changes and boosts in stats
but if you'd like to know everything
about everything you should totally
check out the outriders
channel as it's packed with everything
you want to know about everything
for me i just want to feel like an evil
superhero
there's way more depth to outriders
which can be seen in the class skill
tree offering a plethora of ways to make
your character the exact way you want
them to be
points acquired in this demo and the
full game can be spent here
which should mean having three of the
same class in one group
will still see three totally different
builds in skills and abilities
this screen looks pretty daunting to me
but it's mainly stat boosts
and if we're unhappy with what we've
picked the tree can be reset
one of the things i admire most about
outriders is its insistence
for us to fight and not sit back that's
because we are rewarded with health and
buffs to play in aggressive ways
and although you can sit back the ai on
the bosses in particular will flush you
out
in this boss fight the minions will
flank around the outskirts while the
boss
who is also altered throws out a fire
tornado which hunts you down slowly
adding an element of spatial awareness
and planning where the heck do you run
to next to stay in charge of the fight
another boss will actually throw down an
electrified shrapnel to wherever you're
stood
and backs it up with a watchlight of
electricity which we must run away from
regardless of position
thanks to those small things the game
feels consistently fast paced
instinctive and aggressive and it's a
welcome adrenaline rush
just in case you weren't aware outriders
is a team-based affair
i personally like playing these games
alone but i know i'm weird like that
this is ideally a three-person adventure
i played randoms a few times but the
most fun i had was with a friend
when we attempted a no-guns playthrough
it was tough but only using abilities
is extremely fun
you'll notice my characters keep
changing appearance it's because our
characters can be altered whenever we
see fit
once we've made our initial decision
this isn't anything world shattering but
there's enough facial type
scars and variants of hair to keep most
of us happy
i'm keen not to go overly detailed on
things right now i definitely think you
should play the demo and see for
yourself if outriders is a game for you
and should you want more coverage just
let me know oh in fact there is another
piece of info you should know about this
demo and it's that your progress during
this time will be taken forward
into the full game all your efforts are
recorded and rewarded
should you choose to you could find as
many journal entries as possible
or maybe mind for iron and gather scrap
which in turn will make your experience
in the full game
more plentiful whilst you're at it look
out for those exotic weapons
which have a tiny chance of dropping in
the demo i've seen some impressive stuff
on twitter and youtube
but i can't find any myself maybe you
could be the one
to find the next ultra rare loot drop i
think this is a good time to end this
i'm going back to my tricks to maine
i'll see you on the battlefield
i'm adam from playstation grenade thanks
again to square enix for sponsoring this
video
i'll see you all next time
[Music]
you